thank you so much for joining us at six
o'clock i'm christian cassadas and i'm
kirsten joyce hundreds of thousands of
visitors headed to the valley for the
largest electronic dance music festival
in north america that kicked off tonight
that's right and with all those people
of course comes the traffic madison
cambro is near the festival grounds and
madison how's it going over there
christian we're near i-15 and craig and
currently you can take a look as traffic
is moving at a pretty good pace but
we're hearing that closer to festival
grounds that is where we're hearing the
majority of backups so for this
three-day carnival how do most people
plan on arriving
we're going to take a shuttle i think
it's the
logical way to go festivalgoer jeff
already has it all planned out and he's
not alone the electric daisy carnival
known as edc starts tonight and for many
taking a cab uber or lyft isn't an
option we've heard that if you take a
tax here in uber it takes really long
but the shuttle is supposed to get you
there you get pre-checked so you don't
have to wait in line i know uber has
been experiencing a lot of delays lately
and i don't want to have to worry about
being stranded even so jd decker with
the taxi cab authority says they have
been preparing for a while now and are
on high alert to make sure things run
smoothly and people stay safe it's a
major transportation
event
and so we're expecting
a big demand for rides we're already
seeing ads in craigslist and online for
people offering rides to um through
social media that kind of thing
and so it's very dangerous for the
public to get into someone's car
who isn't a licensed on app
transportation network company driver or
a licensed and permitted cab driver
because
the state has no idea who these people
are the festival starts tonight and will
run until sunday evening at the las
vegas speedway
and as for pricing many festivalgoers
say calling an uber cab or lyft may be a
cheaper option to get to and from the
festival but still it is not worth the
headache that is why they are counting
on the shuttle service reporting live
madison kimbrough live local now